marvel fans i am joined by sochi gomez
how's it going i'm doing great i'm
nervous i'm excited
what are you looking forward to seeing
most in this film tonight um well number
one my homies uh benedict cumberbatch
and benny wong got to support the crew
i'm really excited to see uh just this
movie in general
um have you been a spider-man fan for a
long time oh yeah
um like who hasn't been since like five
years old i mean are you kidding me
that makes sense you're you're right so
there's quite a bit of crossover between
the cast and the cast in your upcoming
film um marvel studios doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness
what is it like working with uh benedict
cumberbatch and benedict wong oh i mean
it's pretty insane i'm a pretty looking
person it's pretty crazy i just love
watching them getting their character in
their zone and it's just been a
wonderful like teaching experience
honestly
it's just crazy to be like oh my gosh i
know these people it's kind of funny
i bet who are you excited to see most on
this red carpet tonight
zendaya
zendaya girl yes i'm excited i'm like
i'm looking here now i'm waiting for the
screen i know
there i hear some screams
could be her
so i heard you skateboard is that true
yes i i do a little bit of skateboarding
but ever since i started getting some
like rolls i was like i can't really
injure myself here so
i just i just graze a little bit no no
crazy trick no no no no
i might be able to have like some fake
blood and stuff for work but
nothing nothing in real life nah that's
a cool skill to have and you just
celebrated your quinceanera yes i did it
was it was during coven and stuff so i
couldn't really have some like huge
thing which i mean i really wish i could
have but i just went around the park and
around just la and just took some photos
[Music]
you